un mar de personas llega a kabul
expulsados por la fuerza de sus hogares
por la insurgencia talibán muchos buscan
refugio en la capital afgana tras
abandonar las provincias norteñas de
tajar y con sur
uno de mis nietos fue alcanzado por una
bala y no pude encontrar un cementerio
así que lo que tiene un hueco cogieron a
uno de mis hijos por la cabeza como si
fuera un cordero y lo degollaron no sé
si el cuerpo de mi hijo se lo han comido
los perros o si alguien lo ha enterrado
los combates se han intensificado en los
últimos días y las fuerzas
gubernamentales se esfuerzan por
resistir a los islamistas
el gobierno afgano pide ayuda
internacional
pedimos a las organizaciones
internacionales especialmente a la onu
que ejerzan más presión deberían
presionar a los talibanes para que
pongan fin a su opresión y sus
brutalidades contra el pueblo la gente
huye de las ciudades bajo control
talibán por las actualidades y también
deberían aumentar la ayuda humanitaria
en kabul y las provincias guardan líneas
de que más problema está el avance de
los insurgentes incluye tanto las zonas
rurales como los centros urbanos ahora
controlan seis capitales de provincias
esta ofensiva comenzó en mayo cuando la
coalición militar liderada por eeuu
entró en la fase final de su retirada
tras 20 años en suelo afgano criticado
por su salida a eeuu defiende su
decisión y alega que las fuerzas afganas
son capaces de repeler a los talibanes
tienen muchas ventajas que los talibanes
no tienen el grupo talibán no tiene la
fuerza aérea no tiene el control del
espacio
eric tienen ventajas ahora tienes que
usarlas tienen que ejercer ese liderazgo
tanto en el aspecto político como en el
widgets hay naciones unidas alerta de
una crisis humanitaria inminente
mientras el vecino pakistán ha reforzado
los controles de la frontera una medida
dicen para evitar la circulación
transfronteriza ilegal y la infiltración
de grupos armados